el problema Resident que en el momento
en el que se ratifique estemos de
acuerdo o no estas agresiones por parte
de la duna y ahora por la firma de
Vladimir Putin significará que irán a
corresponderse como tierras de la
federación rusa por tanto en cualquier
momento que sufra cualquier tipo de
agresión legítima o no en esos
territorios Rusia aplicará su normativa
su dictamen militar vale su producto con
lo militar y considera que es un riesgo
vital a su seguridad nacional y entonces
poder utilizar cualquier tipo de acción
que considere pertinente para
recuperar o para castigar a quién
invadido su territorio en eso se incluye
en su doctrina militar el uso de armas
nucleares tácticas o estratégicas Es
decir de alcance ilimitado pero de
máxima destrucción recordemos que Putin
a pesar de que la guerra no le ha ido
como él pensaba sigue guardado un gran
arsenal de misiles sobre todo el burros
del modelo sarma y también todo lo que
es los sistemas no guiados los drones no
guiados que está comprando que ha
comprado a Irán y que son de alta
efectividad y que está ahora mismo
utilizando por tanto Aunque No utilice
la vanguardia utiliza el sistema y nada
más pues ya tiene 300.000 soldados o
intentando tener 13.000 soldados esa
frontera recordemos que en poco más de
15-20 días Será muy difícil empezar a
combatir en Ucrania por la bajas
temperaturas por tanto es una norma
digamos militar quedarse en un
establishment de fronteras de hasta que
vengan a la primavera y en ese momento
será cuando veamos qué va a hacer cada
una de dos partes El problema es que
Ucrania sienta en el territorio ruso
puede sufrir ataques incluso nucleares
tácticos nucleares y a saber qué haría
la otan la Unión Europea y Estados
Unidos y gran detalle que es básicamente
los apoyos que tiene